(action music)
- Did you see that?
- Yeah.
- You see that?
(car speeding sound)
- Sorry for yelling.
- One, two, three, four.
(rock music)
- What if I told you, I know
what happens when you die.
You become a ghost.
That's part of being dead?
- Is the freedom you could take
out some truly evil people.
(smashing glass)
- Ahh. Was that a bad guy?
- We answer to no-one.
- What you say Robinson's?
Ready to go through the looking glass?
(swooshing music)
- Where going to find Tim.
(upbeat music)
(drama music)
- Chaos, is the most
dangerous thing in this world,
but, without control, chaos will kill you.
- So that's all life is to you,
monsters and money.
- It's all it needs to be.
- I'll tell Charley
what's happening and Kathy
you then hand him the envelope.
- Can you unserve?
- What do you mean?
Like take it back?
- I'll never really get
to be his parent again.
He needs to know that I fought for him.
- Pope's can't resign.
- If you do this, you will
damage the crepecy forever.
- I will no longer sit on
the chair of Saint Peter.
- Your mistaken, your.
- Silence.
- I cannot play this role anymore.
(upbeat music)
Oh.
(swishing skirts)
(upbeat music)
(light airy music)
- Hello, and welcome to
Christmas with my Father.
It's basically going to be
like any family Christmas.
There's going to be arguments and
uncomfortable guests, and at
some point an elderly man will
fall asleep halfway through
saying something racist.
(laughter)
(light upbeat music)
(upbeat music)
- Thunder.
- Do you have any names to share?
- No.
- I want this baby to have a normal life.
- Our child will be heir to the kingdom.
- I don't know if I'm ready
to be a Queen and a Mom.
- I can't even reach my own slippers.
- Allow me.
- Perfect fit.
- He even posted these horrific videos
of him allegedly torturing
and killing cats.
- I wasn't going to
stop until I found him.
- There's a price to pay,
there's consequences for your actions.
(fast music)
(light and airy music)